- Dude that guy hit my
car and totally sped away.
- You saw what he looked like?
- Yeah, he was taller,
dark, um, dark skin,
like dark hair, kind of looked like you,
I guess a little, kinda.
- So he was black?
- Uh, yeah, he's black.
(upbeat music)
- This is my friend Jasmine and Curly.
- Hi.
- Nice to meet you.
(speaking Spanish)
- Yo fellas, what up?
Let's take a selfie right here.
- Cool.
- Aha.
Oh, let me change the filter, yeah.
- Oh Jesus Mary and Joseph.
What? Everyone says that.
- Girl, no they don't
(laughing) What?
- Anyone ever tell you
you look like Idris Elba?
What?
(ubeat music)
- Oh shit,
I'm sure I could go talk
to him to let you slide.
Oh, hell no.
- Girl, just take that ticket.
- No you talk to him.
- Why me?
- I'm saying a word (censored)
- Who are you, why aren't
you dancing though?
It's a good song.
- Eh.
- Yo, you having a good time man?
- Yeah, I'm just not really
feeling the music yet.
- This is my song.
(upbeat electronic music)
(laughing)